oh my gosh it's such a nice evening and
but all these fans came out to support
the movie and it just means a lot they
can expect an extraordinary battle this
is the Battle of five armies and Peter
Jackson has made something truly truly
incredible you've got dwarves you've got
elves you've got the orcs everyone's
coming together on this battlefield
battlefield and and the IMAX really
gives it that depth that it requires and
you know it's a modern epic The Hobbit
The Hobbit and and the IMAX is really
dealing would you see them I mean I
can't imagine middle-earth being in
anywhere but New Zealand it's got that
wild quality that there's something very
pure about it it's the thing I think
I'll miss most about these movies coming
to an end is getting the opportunity to
go to New Zealand the thing about these
films that is so special is simply
I can't even conceive of the new
shepherds Tolkien stories through the
cinematic world in a way that is I mean
I I I watched the movie last night for
the first time and I was just so
you